hey you mentioned jay getting involved
in the weed game
now jay's not uh no like i don't
i don't know jay-z but i don't know him
to be a smoker
no so well not before i think you know
more and
more now than that yeah i mean you know
you're
one of the biggest weed icons in hip-hop
history
so when guys like who who are kind of
coming from the outside of that world
come in
like like how do you feel about that
well
when there's people like hov i i don't
i would never feel no it's like a boss
move almost it's like yeah of course
of course yeah why not not why it's like
that's like him getting mad because i
don't want to be a rapper
you sit down little [ __ ] i got this
it's like nah
[ __ ] that but that's like i understand
he probably
you know wasn't
at the forefront of it or like you know
putting in the work on the on the side
that we were
but to be faces of it you dig what i'm
saying and do it the right way i think
that's the real goal
and just the i see the end goal and the
more
you know bosses and big people and jay-z
has a lot to do with
um you know the jail system and the laws
100
man so uh the fact that there's people
right now across this country that are
doing like serious prison time for like
minimal amounts of weed is insane still
so he don't know how to
he don't even have to smoke a joint i'll
smoke it
he'll smoke it for him yeah just just
keep us good i mean you're on your way
to like i mean i feel like you've been
making so many mogul type moves over the
last decade like you know
you got the [ __ ] on postmates yeah hot
box box
hot box by whiz i mean there's just so
much stuff that you have your hands in